then let us begin with your opening
statement mr. Page whoa opening
statement
so how can you give an opening statement
and summarize your case if you have no
idea what your case is or what the case
is about that's uh it's bad news for for
Phoenix right
[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
today we're covering Phoenix Wright Ace
Attorney a anime manga based on a video
game that was written in Japanese and
translated into English so who knows
what we're gonna get into today my
understanding based on your comments is
that this isn't based on any particular
legal system but it's a combination of
the Japanese and American system I am
NOT an expert in the Japanese legal
system so I will be looking at this
through the lens of an American attorney
because that's what I know best if I get
something wrong please leave me a
comment in the form of an objection as
the judge and jury in this case I will
either sustain or overrule your
objection based on its legal merit and
as always stick around until the end of
the video where I give Phoenix Wright
Ace Attorney a grade for legal realism
so without further ado let's dig right
in to Phoenix Wright Ace Attorney
defense lawyer Phoenix right okay
attorney I just earned my badge a few
months hey I think I recognized that
area so that looks like the nakameguro
area of Tokyo along the maguro River
where they have all the cherry blossoms
really pretty area of Tokyo go so I'm
still a rookie did he say got a badge in
the US at least you don't get a badge
police officers get badges you take the
state bar exam and you become admitted
to the bar and you know where any sort
of lapel pin except for maybe an
American flag lapel pin so don't know
what jurisdiction actually issues a
badge potentially a gun to their defense
attorneys in fact I'm beginning
arguments in my first real trial today
[Music]
so he is on his first day as an attorney
and he's giving an argument in trial
that's that's pretty crazy trials take
months sometimes years to litigate and
you would never start on day one giving
an argument as a new attorney that's not
something that should ever happen if it
does something went terribly terribly
wrong
always so ambitious this is a homicide
case how many people would take one on
for their first trial yeah also most
defendants in a homicide case would not
ever use an attorney who had never done
any sort of trial work before and it was
their first day that's definitely not
what you want in a defense attorney I
know what I'm getting myself into boss
do you have to take it because I owe it
to him what's the significance of the
keychain the defendant yes actually I've
known the guy ever since we were in
grade school he's part of the reason I
wanted to be a defense lawyer in the
first place let's hope you can clear his
name ah okay so Phoenix right apparently
knows the defendant that can be very
problematic because you don't want your
emotions to get in the way of your
defense you have certain ethical
obligations to your client and if your
emotions get in the way of that and also
if you're a
yes who might testify to the character
of that defendant then you would mainly
be conflicted out of representing them
so there's a lot of issues here
representing someone who was a childhood
friend I would never recommend for
someone to represent someone that they
know so well that's that's not a good
idea
there's no ways guilty but how will I
convince the judge do you not have have
you not spoken to your client okay and
they're separating people so this is a
very ornate courtroom that would be more
suited to an appeals court not a trial
court at the criminal level
[Music]
Winston Payne and he's apparently
wearing the same thing that he was
wearing on the day of the murder
you want to put your client in the best
light forward so that's why defense
attorneys if they have to will provide a
suit and tie to their clients in order
to you know make them look a little
better than if they just walked in off
the street you would never want to wear
just a t-shirt with some crazy hair and
a goatee to court you'd want to dress
them up a little bit so that they don't
look like a hooligan like this guy kind
of looks like a frat guy or something
don't forget to argue a solid defense
you have to believe in him and his
innocence right not necessarily all
clients are owed an advocate and often
you are conflicted because you may see
the evidence and you may believe that
they are guilty or liable of what
they're accused of I have heard from my
public defender friends those people who
provide defenses to the indigent that it
can actually be harder if you truly
believe that someone is innocent if you
aren't sure and you're just giving them
a defense you can go through the motions
and you can give them the best defense
possible but
you really believe that they're innocent
of a particular crime then it can
actually be harder because you are
worried that they may you know go to
jail or be convicted of something that
they didn't do which can actually make
it harder for public defenders this
Court is hereby in session gathered
today to hear the case against mr. Larry
Butz the prosecution is ready your honor
the defense is ready your honor then let
us begin with your opening statement mr.
Payne whoa
opening statement so the opening
statement is what you gave at the
beginning of trial and it seems like
there has been very little time that has
passed between the day of the murder and
this day in court Larry Butz is
apparently wearing the exact same thing
that he was wearing on the day of the
murder
and it doesn't seem like phoenix wright
has actually spoken to his client yet
however at the bare minimum
you've got to talk to your client you've
got to talk to them you've got to do
some investigation about the facts
you've got to conduct discovery the
prosecution is obligated to turn over
the evidence that they have to the
defense and you are obligated to review
that information before the trial that
he hasn't apparently spoken to his
client yet and it's day of trial it has
to give it an opening statement that's
crazy how can you give an opening
statement and summarize your case if you
have no idea what your case is or what
the case is about that's uh it's bad
news for Phoenix for Phoenix right we've
identified this statuette of Rodin's the
thinker as the murder weapon all right
which I would like to submit to the
court at this time generally exhibits
would be determined before the trial
goes forward representation did you just
hear the lawyer guy it's Rodin not
modern and this was a gift I made for my
girlfriend do you mean you sculpted this
why is he speaking this is opening
statements the attorneys make an
argument or they say what the f
is going to show for the rest of the
trial this is not the time for the
criminal defendant to say anything at
all especially things that are
inculpatory that's you need to get your
client to shut the hell up at this point
fingerprints we're indeed all over the
weapon your honor shut up shut up this
would be all over
general that's good advice just tell
your client to take my case man I can't
but now like to call mr. butts to the
stand your honor Phoenix right not get
to make an opening statement
if trial has started then the
prosecution will make an opening
statement and they will explain what's
going to happen during the course of the
trial it's generally not the time for
argument then there will be a recess and
the defense will be able to make their
opening statement so it is very
problematic that here the defense is not
allowed to make any statement whatsoever
now I don't know what opening statement
you could possibly make when you have no
idea what the facts are you haven't
spoken to your client and you have no
idea what arguments are going to be made
and what's good for your client and
what's not but still he needs to be
afforded an opportunity to explain his
case we also found a photograph taken on
this trip Your Honor I would also like
to submit these items as evidence I'll
accept okay so the prosecutor here has
not laid any kind of foundation to allow
these exhibits into evidence he's just
simply said that here's this photograph
and here's this passport he hasn't
established that those pieces of
documentary evidence are what they
purport to be and he certainly hasn't
established through this witness that
the foundation has been laid you have to
establish a foundation before you're
allowed to bring evidence in but there's
a more fundamental problem here
the first witness that the prosecution
has called is the criminal defendant now
in the u.s. at least criminal defendants
have a right against self-incrimination
so they don't have to testify if they
don't want to now if they do testify
then the
Scooter will get an opportunity to
cross-examine but it's crazy
that the first witness the prosecution
has called is the defendant and the
defense hasn't objected they have
allowed this to go forward they they are
just asleep at the wheel at this point
and this is really really bad lawyering
sister saw it to the best of your
recollection please tell the court what
you saw the day of the murder why is the
judge asking questions here now
sometimes a judge will ask follow-up
questions they are they have a certain
amount of leeway in the court it's their
court they can sort of do what they want
but to start off the examination it
should be the prosecutor he should be
asking the questions laying the
foundation and establishing the
narrative of what happened it's improper
for the judge to be doing that kind of
in-depth questioning why use a payphone
was there not one closer to the scene
yes but unfortunately due to some
utility repairs there was a scheduled
blackout in the area from one to six so
he couldn't use it
the phone would be completely inoperable
all right again the prosecutor is not
allowed to answer questions in an
examination and the prosecutor can't
just magically pull out some record and
enter it into evidence especially in the
in the middle of an examination of a
witness it has nothing to do with that
information this is very wacky there you
have it the motive weapon and a witness
placing butts at the scene okay
something wrong is it is a prosecution
resting here
no mr. right begin your
cross-examination oh so the defense
finally gets to cross-examine a witness
here right now there's so many
constitutional violations that this
would be declared a mistrial like
immediately this would be overturned on
appeal within weeks of the of the
verdict coming down this is crazy
you say you found the body at 2:00 p.m.
are you absolutely certain of the time
yes without a doubt but according to the
autopsy report the victim died sometime
after 4:00 p.m. it's right here in black
and white okay now while this might seem
like a good argument you're
contradicting the witness with a
coroner's report you're really not
allowed to ask those kinds of questions
of this witness this is a lay witness
who was there at the scene but this
witness is not a coroner not a doctor
and was not involved in the autopsy of
the victim so he has no knowledge about
the autopsy report and so whatever
testimony he might have about the
autopsy report is totally useless the
only time that you would want to bring
up the autopsy report is if you called
the coroner up to the stand which you
should in this particular case and what
you would want to do is verify that the
coroner was absolutely certain about the
time of death examination is not the
time for argument the time for argument
is in your closing arguments it's simple
really all we have to do is cause the
clock to sound right here and now yeah
okay she's apparently offering testimony
as well that is certainly a bizarre way
to announce the time but I'm sorry to
say it doesn't prove anything one way or
another so this judge is making a
classic mistake between evidence being
helpful
aka probative and being sufficient to
prove the entire case no one can ever
prove their case with one piece of
evidence what you're doing is you're
building a mountain one stone at a time
or you're trying to create reasonable
doubt one stone at a time and after a
while if you have enough stones then you
can have a mountain of evidence in your
favor here the defense is creating
reasonable doubt no thanks to their own
really terrible lawyer one piece at a
time through every piece of evidence it
really really bugs me when I see people
make the same
error that the judge has here where they
say oh that piece of evidence whether
it's in a trial or in politics or
what-have-you and they say well that
doesn't prove what you're saying is true
no maybe it doesn't but it helps prove
it and along with all of this mountain
of evidence that does prove the case
well you have to look at everything
we've together the judge is not doing
that here but it doesn't matter one bit
if the clock is running slow today
because you can't prove that it was
running slow on the day of the murder
again so this witness in addition to
answering a question that wasn't asked
and the attorney making an argument in
the middle of an examination is making
the same the same error that the judges
he's saying well just because you've
shown something that's very damaging
that doesn't go all the way you know
you've advanced twenty yards but you
haven't actually entered the end zone
he's saying well it's not worthless
that's not true
you made forward progress you might not
have gotten all the way but you're
getting there and you're putting all the
pieces together and together they've
probably already established reasonable
doubt well well as the attorney he
doesn't have to answer any question you
know he's got lots against you but also
the defense attorney here isn't trying
to show that the witness in particular
committed the murder all he has to do is
show that there's a reasonable doubt
that his client did there's a big
difference that's often why defendants
actually don't take the stand because
it's not their burden to show that they
are innocent all you have to do is show
that the prosecution hasn't met their
burden or that there is a reasonable
doubt associated with the prosecutor's
case the defense especially in a
criminal case bears no burden whatsoever
if you have nothing further I have no
other option than to release mr. Samet
from the stand I take time out of my day
to relive this horrible experience and
you call me a murderer you might want to
reconsider your career mr. right and as
with defendants if there's no question
pending the witness should
be speaking and also if you need time to
look into something or to recoup then
you would just ask the judge for a short
recess that's very common so you're
gonna have time to put things together
it's not going at the breakneck pace of
this this anime according to her
passport the victim had just been
overseas the time difference between
Japan and New York is 14 hours so when
it's 4 p.m. here it's 2 a.m. there 2 is
4 that's 2 hours difference so this is
not something you would want to bring up
with this particular witness but there
is a vehicle to bring in evidence that
is basically incontrovertible and is
called judicial notice if you have
evidence of something that you don't
want to bring in a particular witness
for example if you wanted to say that
the time difference between New York and
Tokyo is 14 hours you wouldn't want to
have to go through the expense of
calling in an expert in date and time
it's a fact that's so incontrovertible
and easy to ascertain that the judge
should allow that fact in without
requiring someone to lay what would
normally be proper foundation so here
though he should not be making an
argument he would be able to ask the
judge take judicial notice of the fact
that the time difference is 14 hours
that's something that would come in
virtually at any time the victim took
the clock with her on her trip but she
hadn't reset it to reflect local time
yet you heard was exactly two hours off
the truth is saw it did it man I really
wish I was allowed to bring in evidence
whenever I felt like it and make
argument whatever I felt like it but
there are lots of laws and rules that
prevent me from doing that but with your
help we can change that arrest mr. solid
immediately the judge is not responsible
for arresting people
and in fact if the prosecutor had seen
this kind of evidence he probably would
have referred the witness to the police
to arrest that man but that is not the
purview of the judge in any case I must
say you've done an incredible job today
in your first trial you defended your
client and discovered the true culprit
thank you no it's time to deliver the
verdict not guilty well there shouldn't
be verdict at all the case just should
have been dismissed the prosecutor
should have realized that it's crazy to
continue prosecuting this guy so
therefore he should just go home alright
so that was Phoenix Wright Ace Attorney
man I don't even know what to do with
that I don't know if that's accurate
from a Japanese perspective but man from
an American perspective that is just all
completely wrong the US Constitution
gives the benefit of the doubt to
criminal defendants because the founders
recognized that it was better for a
guilty man to go free than an innocent
man to be convicted of a crime they
didn't commit
all of those things were a due process
violation that probably would have been
overturned on appeal but it never should
have gotten to that point and frankly
the lawyer on the defense side was
terrible he wasn't objecting when he
should have been he was allowing the
other side to make argument when they
shouldn't have been so all in all I
would give Phoenix Wright Ace Attorney a
d-minus it is all over the place it's
all completely wrong and it's a terrible
example of lawyering in general if you
liked this video please click like and
subscribe so you don't miss the next
lawyer Reax video and by the way I put
together a playlist of all my prior
videos including my reaction to the Good
Wife and suits I think you'll love it